Walking Dead has now gotten so big and
so has so dominated the culture they are
now there are colleges that are offering
courses where you can study The Walking
Dead
yeah as the creator how do you feel
about that it's flattering but stupid I
don't know I just feel like it's a waste
of parents money yeah you know yeah if
people get a lot of student debt
you know the loans and stuff sure you
gotta you know like 15% of that debts
for a Walking Dead class I'm not gonna
feel good about that right that's not
that just seems like a waste of time
okay and I don't know maybe you're
getting something out of it I don't know
what that would be know what so you
heard it here if there is a college I
don't do that don't go don't don't take
that don't take that point I'm making
friends you're making friends now if
there's a Conan O'Brien course
that I could see there being some value
get a little piece of that you see and
that's a listen if I was getting a piece
of these Walking Dead courses then you'd
be completely different still then I
mean I can the educational value alone
yes monumental right well save that save
that clear after getting a piece yeah I
mean if I could start natural walking at
college now we're talking yeah
you